how you doing people this is the Reuben
report I'm the man who invented buttered
coffee Dave ruin and I have Gina grad
and Brett Erick with me and they have a
lot to say so let's get right to it uh
CNN you know CNN they say they're the
most trusted name in news I'm starting
to suspect that may not be the case they
are really just terrible uh of course
yesterday uh five Israelis were killed
uh in the just the endless conflict
that's going on over there uh so I don't
even want to talk about that cuz I know
everybody agrees on the Middle East so
why even have to bring anything up about
that uh but I do want to talk about
CNN's coverage so uh here's a clip and
remember five uh Israelis were killed in
a synagogue see if you notice anything
strange here is Slaughter of innocent
people while they're praying in a
synagogue um I there's no doubt in my
mind that uh it's not even murderers
because animals don't behave like this
to get into a synagogue with a butcher
knife and to slaughter in people while
they pray okay so clearly that was the
mayor of uh Jerusalem and he was saying
synagogue several times I don't know if
you saw the Chiron on the bottom said
mosque okay these things happen we've
got another clip from CNN later in the
day now among the wounded are two of the
police officers who arrived at the scene
one of them apparently in critical
condition now uh the Israeli officials
quickly coming out to condemn uh the
attack the Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu pointing the finger
at Hamas but also at the president of
the Palestinian Authority Mahmud Abbas
accusing him of incitement against
Israelis okay again a bit of an odd lead
there in that police shot killed two
Palestinians they shot the people that
had just killed the five other people
little bizarre um what happened to the
Jews control the media I thought the
Jews control the media I'm on the
internet I know what people are saying
about the Jews I guess they're not doing
a great job with the uh with the media
anymore yeah I'm no orthodox you know
labovich devout Jew but I I do know that
a Jewish temple is not called a mosque
so and I'm terrible at games where it's
like okay find the we find the thing
that's missing I'm like I know I'm going
to fail this I saw right away that it's
not called a Jewish mosque yeah um so
yeah what is going on okay so I just
want to be very clear I don't want to
make this about what's going on in the
Middle East at all or about taking sides
on the conflict or any of that this is
purely I want to make this purely about
our media and CNN in particular our
either one of those remotely how is
nobody fired there was a half retraction
late later in the day because of another
headline that they screwed up it's it's
a lower third you know guys let's take a
minute here because I worked in a
newsroom and in The Newsroom there's a
person in the corner one of 30 people
there and people are shouting at them
and it's their job to literally on an
ancient keyboard that's like this big
yeah sit there and be like oh sorry let
me change that right now and they have
to type it really quickly and there's
also I I don't know how CNN does it but
they're actually up to 36 hours of news
a day in their news cycle and so because
of that there's a lot that happens um I
think there's tons of other stuff that
CNN does wrong I think that second one I
still don't know what was wrong with it
because because the headline they're
talking about that the two people that
are killed are the two terrorists that
not the five people that they just
killed right so another thing that has
happened in in in my interpretation of
the media is there's like a kind of news
story that comes along when this news
story starts you kind of identify what
kind it is and and when you watch like a
story about Israel and Palestine a lot a
certain number of people are like all
right let's dial in but most people are
like oh okay so it's still up
there right okay I'll sit here and wait
until Blitzer tells me about a cat that
climbed up a tree W yeah you know what I
I have to start by saying and it with
literally no irony that I really do
appreciate you giving us a little
insight on the sad dude with the big big
keyboard because I I don't know anything
about that and that that is really good
to know however I am so sick of people
making excuses and I'm not saying you
I'm saying in general people making
excuses for this kind of stuff like do
your job if you fine you can't do it I
get it you can't do it somebody else
will do it and if you did it wrong and
you screwed up apologize I'm so I'm just
so sick of that being okay yeah so I
basically agree with that premise that
yes it's yes this guy probably gets paid
pretty shitty it's a 36 hour news cycle
in 24 hours I get it it's high pressure
it's live breaking news etc etc but the
guy said synagogue like five times in
that little clip or three times in that
little clip it's like shouldn't or
shouldn't they have at least come back
to the anchor and him been like uh
actually but like more insight to that
what does happen when it's wrong is
there's like this groan that emanates
Through The Newsroom from the per first
person who noticed it from the control
room and it's like and then there's like
real intense cuz during the in the
control rooms of all these news shows
it's like shouting and screaming like
the sorc and idea of it it really is
like get it on turn it you got to do
redo so if if it updated later to be
fixed You' got to understand that that's
a thing however I do acknowledge it is a
mistake and if you keep making mistakes
like this maybe it's a bigger thing and
that's the thing if if it is if the
media is Jew run wouldn't one of the Jew
run Jews tell the kid to please change
it from MOS to synagogue just because
that's what it's called it's just too
busy rolling in money and you throw up
the gold maybe he couldn't hear over his
large horns well on that note I'm not
the only one that is not happy with CNN
I want CNN to be better because we all
know what fox is on one side and what
MSNBC is on the other side and although
I believe that the future of news is
online uh it would be nice if there was
one channel we could trust but have you
heard of this John Stewart guy he also
not happy with CNN and he told that to
fared
Zakaria I want to get one last uh
Mission from you please when you when
World historical things like the green
movement are happening the Arab uh
spring are happening yes yes where do I
get my news you get my new watch these
Brave corespond T here what I I put I
set a Google alert for
Blitzer and then and then I just
wait say honestly we have a CNN
exclusive tonight the Empire State
Building is blue during the Green
Revolution you watch CNN and appreciate
the brave reporting the reporters let me
tell you something the reason why I make
fun of certain aspects of CNN is to be
inspired by the brave reporting is to
want more good and and so that's that's
all it is you want more CNN I want more
of good CNN CNN is very similar to the
doll
Chucky sometimes it's good
Chucky but you really got to watch out
for bad
Chucky but we're we're all inspired by
the good stuff no question next on but
we're all inspired by the good stuff I
love that so CS so yes I think most of
us agree with what JN Stewart's doing
and that's why John Stewart is far more
trusted than pretty much everyone on CNN
um are you guys with me on this like you
missed the best part of the clip when
Putin what he what fared says next he's
like ah thank you we'll try to do more
of the good CNN by the way the new story
is that Putin's trying to put the moves
on the first lady of China that's
literally what he does next it's so
amazing exactly yeah we have to pick and
choose what how much of this stuff we
can show you oh for sure but just to add
what happens next what happened
literally right after that clip yeah um
but are you guys with me on this that
look we're all in the online news world
so I believe that online news that's
where you can pretty much get a lot more
truth because you know we're not
corporate controlled blah blah blah and
we're not you know this is done by
clicks you can choose what to watch and
all that stuff um wouldn't you want CNN
to be better every time there's a
breaking news and they screw up the
thing like like the mosque thing that we
just talked about or the Boston bombing
and they speculate we're not going to
speculate and then they speculate for an
hour I'm always like I want it to be
better I want to trust the news anymore
and and I don't know if this is super
jaded and and lazy and a cop out of me
to say but I don't even want C CNN to be
better I just want them to be honest I
don't care anymore about making the any
of these companies better I don't care
anymore about people saying Fox you know
be better be just be honest and honestly
I don't believe you can be impartial
unless everybody hates you so be honest
you're not impartial you believe what
you believe and that's great and the
people who also believe what you believe
will love you so just just just own up
to it you know what I mean honesty in
media has Gina grad gone nuts saying
like don't don't try to have your cake
and eat it too if you want to be an
be an but admit that's
what you're doing yeah when you say that
online news you can have a lot more
truth you can have a lot more truth you
can also have a lot more just
nonsense nothing so I think what Stuart
points out really well is that on CNN
with their resources they can have a lot
of really great investigative journalism
but they also can have like the ratings
grab and not enjoy the luxury of you
know we shoot this show we can edit it
if something bad happens in it we could
take it out they're live all the time
that's the other end of that sword and
unfortunately it cuts really really deep
yeah just for the record I'm pretty sure
in the year and a half we've been doing
this show I think we've edited for
Content maybe maybe twice on something
that I really fact screwed up every once
in a while maybe literally in a year and
a half hair that's supposed to go this
way goes this way other than that you
pretty much uh live DET tap yeah so uh
so you alluded to this in the earlier
segment but so does the 24-hour news
cycle just make this impossible like we
want these guys to be better just but
because they have to talk for 24 hours a
day they just simply the chirons get
screwed up they speculate when they when
they say they're not going to speculate
they that's the next thing that they do
always so is that part of it that they
just because they feel like they have to
just keep talking well yeah and when you
put it that way I think it's it's mighty
convenient of us on the other hand to
sit here and and pick them apart when
when people do you you want to sit there
and put a pot of coffee on and read the
comments on uh this EP or any episode
because we do the same thing we're you
know we're giving our opinions we're
reporting the news we're doing all this
stuff and every once in a while we make
a mistake or we say something and later
it comes out that it was something else
so we're in the media too you know we're
not absolutely and believe me I'm not
saying I'm above it but I do think your
point about what John's saying about the
resources they had if I had those kinds
of resources it wouldn't change my
ability to be truthful and and try to
you know spread some I I agree with you
and I do think there is like a fatigue
that happens with the production of live
news and I I was doing daily you know
Daily News and for a while and man
it gets there's definitely that instinct
that you have that I had to fight I'm
not going to put it on anyone else that
I had to fight of like uh here's a story
here's how people who watch my show
would want me to handle it and here's
the fat joke I make about Chris Christie
and all that stuff and you really do
have to push yourself now I the more I
think that way the more I say you can't
keep making excuses that like oh I'm
sorry my job is hard a lot of people
have hard jobs that doesn't mean they
can just take a mental moment off yeah
and by the way they call themselves the
most trusted name in news so if that's
what you're going to call yourself how
about show it don't say it that's a
relative term because look at all the
other names in news it doesn't say much
that's a perfect ending so let's move on
okay so we know that the uh the decision
in the Darren Wilson case in Ferguson is
going to come down it could come down
today it could come down uh sometime
they're saying before December 1st uh
whether he will be indicted for uh
killing uh Michael Brown and already
everyone saying that there is going to
be violence they've already declared a
state of emergency in Ferguson uh it's a
big mess we've got a video with a little
more
info worried about the violent pass and
with new Intelligence coming in the FBI
has sent a bulletin to police across the
country it warns that violent
individuals will likely try to exploit
peaceful protests and attack law
enforcement in Ferguson and possibly
Nationwide according to the bulletin
suspects could be armed with knives and
guns and tactical gear like tear gas
masks and Bulletproof
vest the warning signs specific recent
intelligence that's causing concern
including threatening
messages okay so basically we're sort of
preempting the Violence by saying that
there is going to be violence I'm pretty
convinced that regardless of whether
he's indicted or not there is going to
be violence uh violence either way I
mean clearly if he isn't indicted I'm
pretty sure there's going to be violence
and I have a feeling that even if he is
when you have this many people together
and so many people with different
motives and everything else I think
there's going to be violence either way
I think you're absolutely right I mean
and I'm not I'm not comparing these two
things but I guess I am because the
first thing I think of is look how crazy
people go when their team wins exactly
but really really people people uh just
Express themselves very physically
sometimes whether they're happy or
they're sad but um and I I agree you
have to prepare for these things you
have to make sure people are safe and
protected however you don't use that as
an excuse to uh show up with gigantic
tankers and Bazookas and get ready to
you know kill everyone in the crowd yeah
so has the precedent already been said
here that there'll be violence because
of what happened and the over
militarization of the police and
everything else like have we already set
that this is in motion already I grew up
in Los Angeles and we do
riots you know and uh done any since
I've in here just for the we also we
also do we do riots when the Lakers win
and this Clippers that's a great Point
um but uh we also do earthquakes and
earthquakes happen you just don't know
when the big ones going to be so I'm
pretty sure something's going to happen
regardless I can't I can't I don't know
the riots why riots would happen if he
is indicted well only because so many
people are going to be out there the
police are still going to be there and
there's just this
undercurrent of like it's just like this
like Amorphis thing and someone just
sets off a firecracker when the reason
one person to set this off when the
reason any of this is happening is
because the police and the the general
public don't really communicate well
it's going to really suck when when that
under is is translating into like this
big national attention moment yeah I
don't know it's it's tough hopefully it
won't be a a a big eruption of violence
it doesn't I mean it sounds like it
should help to have tanks there to stop
violence but it but but it's not going
to I understand the idea to bring tanks
but that's just really not going to help
at all go ahead well doesn't it seem you
know just the way they put it like there
could be a you know this could end Earth
uh there could be guns and knives there
there could be a lot of things but but
doesn't it sound like they're setting
themselves up to excuse their behavior
and that's sort of well I don't even
know if it's to excuse their behavior or
just like I sort of feel like the media
kind of wants it too when we talk about
this with ebola and everything else
where there's just always this lead in
that gets everyone Juiced like the the
protesters now know ah the FBI is
talking about us already like and also
doesn't it help the protesters argument
if there is violence unfortunately you
know what I mean yeah it's sure then
they go well look there's more violence
so we're we're even more screwed
everybody wins in the the worst possible
way if something horrible happens yeah
so what are the police supposed to do
because obviously those images were
awful and tanks and the sniper with the
guy right in front of him and all that
stuff it's terrible we don't want that
on our streets obviously but if there
are riots what are the police and the
National Guard actually what's within
their right to do if they're looting
stores and and all that stuff well
there's there's certain you know they
instead of putting bullets in their guns
they put like little bean bag pellets so
there there's they have riot gear I
assume you use that
um anybody the problem is yeah if don't
erupt into the violent shooting spree
just to get it to stop is but then
someone could shoot at them with a live
bullet that's what I mean about this
like endless thing that I mean this gets
to the heart of like why maybe it
happened in the first place like the the
the idea of being a police officer is
frightening to me still like no no if if
the situation was such that the the
police officer was not provoked at all
like that's not okay but I can't imagine
what it's like to be a police officer
the same way I can't imagine what it's
like to be profiled on the street you
know other than being like really
non-threatening which is what people you
know determine about me because I just
don't work out I you're pretty
threatening I've seen you late at night
wandering the streets of LA I call you
Surly thank you thank you so much um
really though is there anything so we
don't know literally this could the
decision could come down while we're
sitting here right the second or it
could come down next week whatever it is
but since since we have this lead time
where we know that this decision is
coming is there anything that anyone can
do to calm tensions CU it seems like
everything we're doing is just
ratcheting tensions isn't there like we
have time now is there nothing we can do
I don't want to speculate here but you
know take away CNN honestly I think just
little chocolate treats if you give
people a bunch of bunch of candy I mean
it does a lot I mean honestly I don't I
don't know the honest answer so
Halloween sequel yeah exactly another
Halloween no costumes I think there's
I'm not a historian but I'm sure there's
been riots in the past that haven't
erupted in a nationwide outrage that
things have been contained things have
uh ended relatively peacefully
relatively quickly without major
Bloodshed and major horror so maybe we
need to go back and look at the tape of
things that haven't ended so
horrifically that this is going to be
what we're talking about in teaching in
schools for the next couple decades yeah
well on that note I hope that I am
completely wrong on this one I fear that
I'm not but I hope uh that I am what you
think comment right down below all right
you guys probably heard about this I
think this is the coolest story of the
week the European Space Agency uh their
Rosetta Mission successfully landed on
the filet Comet I hope I'm pronouncing
that right I heard it pronounced about a
thousand different ways uh this is a
giant moving comet uh and of course of
course the conspiracy theories are
flying uh so we've got a little
something from the guardian and then we
got a whole bunch more uh so this is
supposedly about a leaked email
uh that was sent to the guardian the
email allegedly from a secret
whistleblowing employee of the European
Space Agency accuses the agency of
blatant coverups in wanting to land on
the speeding Comet and attaches photos
which claim to reveal the true inner
workings of comet
67p now we've got an excerpt from the
email itself comet 67p is not a comet
some 20 years ago NASA began detecting
radio bursts from an unknown origin out
in space it would later be known that
these had likely come from the direction
of the nown named Comet 67p it does show
signs on its outside of machine-like
parts and unnatural terrain whatever
this object is it did not ask to be
found or
scrutinized and uh of course videos are
popping up all over YouTube where people
claim that they know exactly what's
going on and we've got one right here
guys I'm going to read an email that
came out a while back check this out
there's something flying across the
surface these are brand new highres
images from the European space agency
and they already knew as we look at this
particular section of the Comet also
appears to be a tower with this Shadow
and it actually looks like a rounded
structure to the right of it that does
is not as distinguishable as that white
disc with the shadow that's flying
across that surface okay that kind of
sounds like something I like his accent
by the way was that Neil degross Tyson
uh no it was brother uh but we've got
even more if you think that's not enough
that something's going on here the
European Space Agency uh well they
confirm that the comet's been making
sort of a a sound or a song If you will
let's
listen
all right the tune's not as catchy as
the sound and the song in Battlestar
Galactica when they were all the syons
were all hearing that but that's that is
something and finally just to put a
little perspective on the size of this
freaking thing let's take a look at how
big this thing is compared to the city
of Los Angeles this is a big ass Comet
oh my all right my two esteemed guests
I've given you guys a lot to work with
here what do you think I mean that that
white thing on the comment that kind of
looked like a radio tower of satellite
or that the
is that the I thought I write it wrong I
thought it was a photo from the probe of
the Lander no no no I don't think so I
don't think so uh then definitely a
spacecraft mhm got to be got to be a
spacecraft but when you put all this
together it's making some weird sounds
the picture kind of you know the
government doesn't like telling us about
these things I'm kind of on board you
know not totally I need a little more
evidence but I have a theory that the
reason why uh one of the reasons why us
president's hair to go white within the
first year of their presidency is
because that first year they're sat down
and told about all the alien activity
and they go insane and they go total
they're terrified and their hair goes
white um what about plausible
deniability remember in Independence Day
when they when they found the aliens and
they told the president and he said why
didn't anyone tell me and they go
plausible deniability remember so they
don't do that no they know but that's
the thing I think okay if it is ah
fantastic we want to know more you know
we want to get in on this whatever
please leave it alone every time I go
hiking and I look at a sunset I swear to
God I'm going to sounds so insane I
don't care it's worth it I sit there and
I go I could seriously be sitting here
in Chains like enslaved right now with
like like hovercrafts going over me and
like you know like on a cha please leave
the aliens alone I don't want to be
enslaved by a a race of demons just let
it be let the comet go by let's continue
to live our lives I think you make a
very valid point there if alien come
here first they have to destroy us right
and if we get there first we'll destroy
them is that pretty that's pretty much
that's the reason you go places you're
not going for the peace conference yeah
I mean I if we blow up Earth that's the
only reason I'd leave Malibu you know
and not that I live there but I like to
go there when be to go on a weekend like
if Malibu's gone then I yeah we have to
go to space I just don't think we're
going for any other reason than we've
completely depleted our own resources
absolutely yeah so it's Avatar we're
going because we need the unobtainium do
rain diamonds on Neptune I mean we're
going to destroy anything we can get our
hands on so please just do it after I
die get do it hold off another 50 60
years and then go crazy so I'm
completely onb that wouldn't the
government so we all think that these
are conspiracy theories or you know area
I always forget it's 51 it's 51 now okay
what's I'm thinking of Club 57 or what's
the studio Studio 54 whatever it is and
the point is there's a lot of freaky
people there too a lot of unidentified
activity a lot of weird
um but wouldn't the governments like
there's this idea that the governments
would never tell us and that maybe they
know for the last 20 years that they
never but wouldn't it behoove them
actually if if we knew that there was
other stuff out there and it was coming
here may wouldn't it maybe unite us we
always talk about how we're so we all
hate each other countries are at War
wouldn't somebody if we knew aliens are
on the way we might go all right maybe
we should kind of work this out
yeah that you that's a good thought
experiment like for sure that should
work but uh people freak out when
there's a new iPhone yeah you know I
think they're going to freak out when
it's like oh my God I mean not only am I
going to want to tell that person I
never told how I feel about them as the
impending apocalypse approaches I'm also
going to want to steal that new iPhone
that's a good point cuz think how
advanced their iPhones are because
they're coming from they would have a
flash on the front for selfies at this
point oh my God I also believe you would
love that oh my God can't wait I would
love for that to happen the next 50
years um so here's what I think I think
you're absolutely right I I think that's
adorable of you and I get why that would
be a good thing but in the society we
live in it doesn't matter what country
you're in what culture you're part of
you know the first thing us
would say because our heads are so far
up our own asses I told you so you
didn't believe in this God and you
didn't believe in this religion and you
did you ate meat and you drank bullet
coffee and you did this and you did that
that's why the aliens are going to kill
us it would be every man for himself
right so it would end up being just like
a race to contact them first and be like
come on our team because these guys over
yeah everybody would turn against each
other more than they already are all
right well speaking of turning against
each other you're not going to believe
this but racism is Alive and Well in the
United States yeah that's right uh after
President Obama was reelected the second
time around uh Jezebel did a story where
they screen captured a gajillion tweets
uh people saying a lot of racist stuff
well then floating sheep which is a
group of geography academics with the
fun name uh they compiled this stuff uh
and they came up with some really
interesting
information as to where here you go
we've got a map for you as to where
these racist tweets are coming from now
the more green you are the more racist
your tweets are and that's the density
of tweets the red dots are the the basic
tweets um but yeah southeast United
States uh a lot of racist tweets coming
out of there I guess that's not a
tremendous surprise this is terrible I'm
racism Mist I'm racism because if you
I'm not racist I'm racism because I
profile where racists will be and I'm
racist Miss cuz I was like probably
Missippi Alabama that's bad of me before
you even saw the I'm like a yeah
probably down there somewhere can we go
back to the map please let's go back to
the map so yeah it's really it's focused
down there the West look at the West
we're doing pretty well out out west
here we're we're not very racist on the
other hand look at Wyoming what a Utopia
on Earth huh yeah they are not sending
out I know yeah um okay so
again this is information based on after
Obama was elected the second time uh I
thought guys and correct me if I'm wrong
I thought that we were post-racial now
and we had put this thing to bed no
there's just more ways to post our
racism that's what it is so instead of
the clansmen actually like burning the
stakes now they can just anonymously do
it on Twitter the best part about the
Twitter is like all the the profile
photos of all these racist people that
are like it's like and then just in the
corner it's like some girl
like right or it's their cat or yeah
it's so amazing yeah you would do me a
favor and don't make I mean I guess
that's the best to make it funny like
you expect it to be like all clansmen
being like Oh yes I do this but then
just to have a kitten be like you're
shocked that the Clans people don't put
their own pictures on their Twitter
account I don't know I'm just I just no
he's shocked that it's coming from a
14-year-old girl in a tank top with a
Hello Kitty headband yeah yeah yeah U
did you guys see that this week that
Anonymous hacked into the kkk's Twitter
so they're now running the kkk's Twitter
so good there's a little the password
was die Blacky die or something like I'm
sure that's all that's how they did it
right it probably wasn't that easy um is
is social media you think like the best
way we can look at ourselves now is it
the best reflection of what really is
going on because if you're a racist now
it's not politically correct to be a
racist in society anymore so this stuff
has just shifted to the online world so
is that a better reflection of actually
how people feel than uh than what we say
to each other face to face or publicly
well you might be right because I
thought it was exact the opposite I mean
online I I was under the impression that
everybody wanted to pretend to be
somebody else the best version of
themselves the funniest the most
politically correct the whatever and
this is showing the exact opposite is
when they're sending these racist tweets
are they trying to be the most Brazen
the most edgy I I don't know yeah what
do you think I I I don't I think it's uh
these are just individuals who don't
really understand how like Twitter works
the they know how branding works good
for their personal brand I'll tell you
that much uh I just think that some of
these might just not not not get it like
they're saying they say things when no
one else is watching so maybe they
haven't had that exposure to like the
general Public's more developed idea of
racial equality and so they unknowingly
are like I say it around here I'm just
going to say it to my friends out here
unfortunately for them I guess
fortunately now they now they find out
what everyone else thinks yeah and they
might think twice um do you guys think
that Obama sort of can't win when it
comes to race like in a certain way you
I think you could make a pretty strong
case that he's been sort of protected in
a way by parts of the media because he
is black and at the same time obviously
there's a huge percentage of people that
don't like him because he's black so is
he just he can't win there was no way to
like sort of come out of this eight
years with it all feeling right right I
mean can't you kind of say that about
all of the other presidents too at this
point because you know there's plenty of
people that say well at least we still
got a white g off and the other and
there's plenty of white people and
plenty of people I think in general that
are like can we get a little diversity
you know everybody starts to feel
oppressed when we have one long line of
the same person running the Free World
so I I don't know that it is it any
different yeah I I'm not sure do I feel
like maybe at the end of this thing for
whatever reason America is going to be
like we need a white guy again like Mitt
Romney is suddenly going to look
attractive again because we need the
most boring white guy which is so sad I
don't even think it's going to help F
boring yeah he can't he can't he wears
mom jeans he can't throw a baseball have
you ever seen a bowl the bowling one was
worse than the Bas yeah it's pretty
terrible uh yeah I I don't know I I
think maybe just to be optimistic we've
got we we can just make a selection
based on what we need most as a nation I
I don't think it will enter in as much
next time I think you know I just think
the discussion is like there's I forget
what magazine but the cover of I don't
know if it's time or one of those
magazines is like is Hillary inevitable
is she still inevitable so it's like the
fact that like a woman gets to be
inevitable you know I I I guess that
maybe says something good about us that
it's not is this woman inevitable it's
like oh here's a name of a person that
we' decided might be the next president
right although when it comes to
inevitable so we have correct me if I'm
wrong on this we have Hillary 2016 then
we have Jeb 2024 then we have Chelsea uh
2032 then Malia
2040 then Northwest then Northwest
by I didn't know Malia was two- term
Malia is going to be two- term Northwest
may not be so that gets us to 2044 who
do you got after that A Smith a Jaden
Smith I'm just saying like at that point
there will be no America anymore we can
only hope will enslaved by aliens at
that point we can only hope all right
let's talk about toilets uh the French
are going to be putting toilets in their
kitchens yeah that's right uh we got a
little more info for you so they just
changed this law in France previously
the law had required that toilets were
not directly accessible from living
rooms or kitchens all right uh the
change to the building code does away
with the prohibition of direct
communication between the closets and
kitchens and living rooms this will
allow contractors to build new toilets
in living
accommodations um all right I'm not
French so I don't know exactly what's
going on here so first off if you're
French please let me know right down
below uh I personally would not want a
toilet in the kitchen you filthy filthy
French people I don't know my mom told
me where you eat oh I I had my I
had that later sorry jumped on it
sorry I
did godamn it sorry Reuben why I'm I'm
sorry no it's all right why is it
because is it because the population
there's too many people they're having
to build smaller hey put it all in one
room who gives a so I do think
there is some element to that that
literally the apartments are getting
smaller and people are look and I lived
in New York City in a tiny apartment
where you know I could basically reach
my stove and poop and you know reach out
the window at the same time so multitask
yeah but it's not so we don't want this
nobody wants this what makes a living
room really it's where I'm most
comfortable and where I can have a snack
and just relax and do your some light
reading that's also where I'm pooping a
lot I a lot of people put TVs in their
bathrooms I'm fine with that really yeah
yeah yeah like when I when I go to a
hotel and I'm like there's a TV here oh
never leaving right but isn't there a
distinction between the toilet and the
living room which if you're watching a
basketball game you don't don't want to
get up you know we've all seen those
like lazy boys that fake it like you got
to you can take a dump and watch the
game okay but that there's some sort of
sanitary difference between taking a
dump in the living room which I suppose
you can rationalize and taking a dump in
the kitchen seems once we started this
conversation it's gone too far like all
right I'll give you a in the living
room all right fine that's fine
is the is the kitchen too far the living
room was too far people love lists I
wanted top 10 places that you'd like to
in your house list God that's so
amazing like I salarium salarium would
be niceass a nice poop on the laai you
knew I was going to get L um all right
so then last point on this whole silly
topic is uh is is the West going
backwards in a weird way like because of
population and we're packing all these
people in uh to these small places that
now we have to have toilets in kitchens
like that something that maybe they had
when they had when you had to cram all
these people into a place way you know
hundreds of years ago or 100 years ago
I'd say and now we're sort of going back
so is the West slipping up here yeah I
think not only are they slipping up but
with we're going to double what go to 10
billion people by 20150 um not only are
they going to put toilets next to
refrigerators but they're going to have
to find a way to make it fancy so
they're going to I predict they're going
to start featuring this in Better Homes
and Gardens and in Vanity Fair and make
it a super fancy experience because
we're not going to have to have we're
not going to have a choice yeah the West
are our days done I'm just picturing all
the times when I like was supposed to
cook something and I put something in
the pan that I was not supposed to put
in there and like if you add poop and
pee to that whole list of things at the
ready it's just going to be a bad
experience so yes the end of West by the
way can we go back to bread for a second
because your posture implies that you
could be because when you take a poop
you're supposed to be very and you're
sitting very kind of oh I can poop
wherever however honestly my girlfriend
gets really mad at me cuz like some
girls have problems with like getting it
getting it out but I I I do whenever
never I'll go like four times a day I
don't care do you think play Candy Crush
and it's out do you think the toilet
people will team up with the crockpot
people and maybe go into business all
right I've had just about enough of this
topic on that note let's move on Germany
this story is actually kind of inspiring
I think uh according to the anhol gof
Nations brand index and I'm pretty sure
I pronounced that wrong sure uh Germany
is now the world's favorite country now
of course Germany's had some problems
remember World War II Nazis all that
they've had a bad rep for a long time uh
and they're still the butt of jokes
often uh but this does kind of show that
things can change so let's take a look
at uh the top 10 countries uh Germany is
number one uh the United States number
two we've slipped we're not number one
anymore we'll get to that in a moment UK
number three France Canada Japan Italy
Switzerland Australia Sweden so none of
those seem that surprising to me because
those are sort of of all the westernized
countries with good civil rights and uh
human rights and things of that nature
and as it says on the right side the USA
which held first place since 2009 and is
still seen as number one in creativity
contemporary culture and educational
institutions suffered from its perceived
shaky record in Global Peace and
security that certainly makes sense uh
with everything going on in the world
right now by the way it's not the gof
Nations uh brand index it's the gfk my
my guy didn't put it in capitals here so
I good
that's good good and by
the way to prove a point uh about our
earlier segment on CNN and correction
see I screwed up and then I corrected it
within 30 seconds that's that's
professional people thank thank you
thank you um all right so the reason I
like this story is because this shows
that people and countries can change and
I really like this Germany has done some
horrible horrible stuff and yet they've
changed and modernized and blah blah
blah you've got something I can see that
glimmer in your eyes I was I'm deciding
whether or not to say like okay um okay
so how long does it take to forget a
genocide all right cool that's that's
that's the statute limitation I think
roughly 65 roughly 65 years yeah um my
knee-jerk reaction for just a bevy of
reasons was you've got to be kidding me
but once I got over myself and and got
over my initial emotional reaction which
I think in you know being Jewish and
being American and being a a human uh
we're entitled to yeah um I thought okay
what have they done to deserve this what
have they done to deserve to take this
number one spot and I'm not exactly a
good this is goingon to shock both you
I'm not really a global policy expert
but um I was told you were sorry your
guy messed up um but but what I do what
I do understand what I do believe to be
true I think about Germany is they have
really gone above and beyond when it
comes to reparations and when it comes
to the policies they've changed when
they I mean you literally you cannot own
a copy of Mind comp is my understanding
um you know they they've the the
reparations they've made to families
that were affected by the Holocaust and
that is that is a standup thing to do as
a nation so I'd like to think that that
has something to do with it obviously
the atrocities are going to haunt people
for centuries and it's it's a horrible
thing and it can't be erased and it
shouldn't be erased but the things that
their country and their government has
done to start to apologize and to start
to heal that nation and heal so many
people I think is commendable So to that
point 65 years or whatever it is my math
isn't perfect but it's pretty good right
like that's actually if you think about
how a nation can change and go from that
to number one in the world popularity
contest I mean that's pretty good yeah
good for them they would and plus like
it helps that the rest of Europe doesn't
have its together like and just Ang
going like all right let's all just get
in a line and handle what's right with
the world right so maybe
that was it was something but you know
so you think they maybe stuff The Ballot
Box cuz they're so organized I mean
that's the thing is like yeah they just
this is what happens when you apply your
talents in the right direction all their
systematizing when it's toward killing
Jewish people like that's not where you
should be putting your ability it's a
lot of wasted energy yeah take your
talents good how do you guys feel about
the USA not being number one on a list
we like to be liked everybody loves us
and they hate us all the time yeah you
know when there's a comment card after a
customer service and you want to give
them a five cuz hey it's fun but you
give them a four cuz there's always room
for improvement keep them humble that's
what I say so that's what they're doing
that's what the rest of the world is
saying we need you you know like Isis no
one else is going to ever do anything
about it so we're going to hate you if
you're there and we're going to hate you
if you're not there but we still need
you United States and second place isn't
nothing but I'm an underachiever so we
also like to be underdogs in America we
we always root for the underdog uh we
also like to be the top dog and the
underdog which is in way masturbation
great Broadway show by the
way uh what's your favorite country good
question putting you on the spot right
now no lead time if you had to pick a
country not the United States let's just
let's just throw United States out for
the purposes of this if you had to pick
another country uh that you really dig
who I got to say I had a great worldwi
summer in the Greek island so I could I
could live up my days there they found
they found democracy great fet cheese uh
for me I'm going to go with my favorite
country being uh uh I really enjoyed
going to Italy recently so it's like
fresh and they barely cook their meat so
that's awesome yeah yeah yeah the pasta
is fresh yeah yeah just what do you like
I'm going to say Canada because they
have they they yeah because they
basically do the right thing in the
world they don't get overreached and
over involved they stand up for the
right principles they have to deal with
us living right below them and also they
have to deal with that threat that every
right- Winger makes constantly which is
that I'm going to move up to Canada and
they have to deal with that and that's
that's not fun and and yet they always
are smiling they're very pleasant every
time I've been there great fun people I
thought you were just going to basically
saying I like cold America yeah exactly
oh I right weatherwise it's not perfect
for me I do like our Southern Califor
yeah it's like I don't like Coke but
I'll have like you know Safeway Select
soda if I can't have I guess I'll take
an RC yeah exactly you see this anti-
Canada stuff that you're I'm putting out
I get it but we're going to the
Mediterranean peace out yeah all right
we got one more for you McDonald's we
talk a lot about McDonald's and they do
a lot of weird stuff pink slime no they
don't have pink slime they're new
commercials that are like ah we're
pretty awful so talk to this board and
it'll tell you how not awful we are and
all kinds of weird stuff uh even the
chicken it's all right anyway uh the CEO
of McDonald's Don Thompson uh recently
spoke at an event at a venture
capitalist firm and uh he was asked what
they were doing to make children
healthier and he said that they actually
tried to take broccoli and make it taste
like
bubblegum it did not work that's right
uh to quote him it wasn't all that
yeah bubblegum flavored broccoli not all
that so they didn't do it um now I know
it's easy to pile on McDonald's and we
do it here often um but should we give
them a little credit for trying to make
broccoli
tastier no oh okay then okay first of
all the one little teeny tiny bit of
slack I'll give them is I don't know
when you guys were sick when you were
little did you ever get that really
opaque disgusting textured but delicious
bubblegum flavored Medicine of course
okay so that was kind of Del grow up in
the ' 80s okay so that like you know
when you put throw a little bubblegum
flavor on some stuff it makes it better
however shame on you McDonald's
everybody has to eat their vegetables
and they're supposed to taste like
vegetables stopping an here's
the thing is everyone loves a taste of
your other food just make broccoli taste
Tes like your other food don't make it
taste like something you're not supposed
to swallow Bravo Brett erck because oil
right why can't they just make it taste
like the other that everyone's
addicted to already it's so good in a
way you're like okay vegetables they
taste like stuff you're supposed to chew
and spit out so like only swallow the
we make otherwise why does broccoli
get such a bad rap now I understand when
I was six did not like the broccoli my
mom wanted me to eat broccoli I remember
it's sitting there on the table you're
not going to leave this table to I love
broccoli now there are many ways little
garlic oil there's so many good things
you can do why why does broccoli get the
bad wrap and Brussels sprouts they're
great oh they're great but as an adult I
didn't eat them till about 2 years ago
and you got to cover in butter bacon um
but but broccoli those cruciferous
vegetables it's a texture thing the
texture is awful raw am I am I right raw
well nobody wants eat raw broccoli but I
guess you could unless slather it in
ranch dressing everybody likes that yeah
yeah at that point you're not making it
healthy anymore but I get it when you're
saying like when I was a kid I was like
I want chicken with nothing on it yeah
and if you can make edible air that's it
but like that's that's what it comes out
but if you have a little cheese you can
sprinkle that on the air we I'll allow
it mother so what would the more
dangerous thing have been here if they
had actually made this work if they had
had bubblegum flavored broccoli and kids
would have been eating that wouldn't
that have done actually more long-term
damage to people eating the right Foods
because then you'd grow up thinking that
your broccoli has to taste like bubble
gum it would have been more have more
long-term damage cuz God knows what they
injected into the broccoli to make it
taste like bubble gum I mean the kids
would go into kidney failure at 8 years
old can you believe that that's
someone's job you know like Professor
Frank can you make this broccoli taste
like bubblegum yes I went to masking
flavor Academy for years just to learn
how to do this it's insane that's a
guy's job for sure we can do anything
though if we can make broccoli taste
like bubblegum we can do anything I know
really all right final thought on this
are we ever going to get food right in
this country every week now I've been
doing something on food and our food
sources and all the awful we're
putting on stuff and Monsanto and all
that stuff uh are we ever going to get
it right or are we just going to be in
an endless high fructose corn syrup
lifestyle forever I'd like to say we can
get it right but we're talking also
about what you brought up earlier the
explosion of population like how are we
going to have a system that puts out
food to to handle all these people the
and when right now it's like if I want
to eat right it's going to cost me a
ton of money to go down to to go
down to Whole Foods it's like twice as
much when I shop there so I don't know
what the solution is and the if I want
to grow it at my house that takes a
certain amount of affluence the people
who are trying to break it break through
into like a high higher level of society
it's it's it's hard not to just go get
McDonald's for your family speaking of
growing it in your house I got this
goddamn squirrel that is eating all my
mint all I have is mint and this
squirrel he's literally and he's mocking
me because he also buries peanuts where
the mint was and it's like am I going
he's leaving his calling card like a
bandit right so yeah exactly he's like
the water Bandit from but the thing is
like I can so my options are I can spray
it with some sort of chemical and then
when I have my mojito I can now be
drinking chemicals which I don't want to
do which is why
growing the Min in the first place yeah
or I can be I'm under the constant
threat of this squirrel so you know you
can't win mesh or something I don't know
some kind of mesh some kind of mesh
however my what would be great is if my
then my front plate it would look like a
freaking jail it would be so sad if
right now that squirrel was with all his
squirrel friends he's like I met the
most amazing generous human ever he's
giving me mint and so I you know I try
to pan bag a little peanuts but I know
this is one-sided cuz that mint is
delicious that is a good point I like
peanuts so why don't I just eat his
peanuts yeah it's very sweet of him he
didn't have to bring you
anything well on that note people we've
learned a little something here I think
uh I want to thank Gina grad and Brett
ER their Twitter is are right down below
follow them comment on all this stuff
what else to people do online tweet
about it and that Facebook and thing and
there must be something else or the the
Snapchat I'm not doing that anymore and
all that good stuff and we will do this
again next
week